welcome to this video playing kira kira
malu with no flag no flag guessing this
time let's see I'm shattering the Queens
Bishop can lead to all kinds of openings
quince Indian on some type of English
opening someone yeah okay the head shock
yeah this type of fun this type of head
shop with taking on default the lightest
consider to be a relatively harmless
it's a bit surprising that player with a
rather high rating as allowing that I'm
okay I want to be five if this is some
already possible or I said is it too
quick maybe okay let's let's say let's
play it it's maybe a bit risky trying to
use this weakening of the queenside just
briefly checking it sits wow it's a
really good account like it's got
thousands of games and i feel i have
never played them i have had i have
played in once it's in the statistics
losing I lost this game
yeah this is in fact interesting yeah I
am the problem is he's quick on the
befall hmm yeah interesting line I
really interesting maybe beef this was
this wasn't so great maybe getting into
the same game he still has this very
weak porn of course but i'm not i'm not
sure about them the dynamics in this
position a weekly as upon weakness is
good but it's just as not only about
static features and I don't know night
look here I go night c5 maybe I should I
should do that kingham King rocker look
see Sam now this is the question hmm I
wonder ever can play king the aid
against that King the aid rook takes f7
King yet just chasing the look all the
time
I don't know if I have an alternative
which should be seven this knight c6
yeah okay let's do that here can now go
to c 6 which is really strange I can do
that and sacrifice an exchange now I can
ah of course Roxy 7 simply rook c7 this
is completely bonkers when I'm playing
really just idiotic yeah hey now look c6
of course he can just go Roxy six well
maybe maybe I can hopeless I'm really
playing hopeless chance at the mood yeah
this is not even good he can just take
could have just played rook c6 check I
mean this is not bad of course it's not
bad at all but it's completely
unnecessary he could have just played
Brooks is sick center and that's it yeah
okay change here he's got he's got two
points for the exchange which is of
course very good compensation but I have
an active King that's important okay b5
and 95 not good
I need to end it counter play badly so
maybe I can get get the night here to
what you 595 an ID 595 yeah okay here
yeah of course that that's quite a
strong center and group t6 is also
coming in 95
yeah i need i need to do i need to get
get a TM quickly if i do i lose any more
time let's see probably over anyway need
to break up the pawns yeah take I'm not
not me to tea or anything this is
probably just lost yeah
I don't have I don't have anything that
I can try really the some this night is
just so strong protect their form check
now you can even play some second rate
moves and win I don't think that that
this was the best but it's completely
enough you should just mega camp king
king is king movie the king is not
helping
talk about no counterplay absolutely no
counterclaim okay maybe maybe the big
pond but he can take and I need to
retreat with the King even check nice
taking so much time as very strange it's
no cheating account or something it is
it's an old account p 3 is got the rope
here
okay it's free I'm nth hmm what might be
fun I just got Kimmy phone okay I love
this guy's love okay brah after going to
offer draw him me check okay check yeah
well I offered to draw I'm not going to
resign wait forfeits on time haha Cham
Cham yeah i'm just in bad shape what can
you do and what he played was was was
perfectly all right of course but here
in this position he also can play a
group here and it's completely useless i
just lost upon and he can go back with
rook it's it's completely you're taking
my plane yeah just just very hard to
understand what I'm doing yeah Roxy 8 is
just good just attacking see form and
should be should be okay I shouldn't be
in trouble I shouldn't be in trouble but
still it's not not easy whatever I did
is just just bad i mean here this is
just blocking the way for the rook to
attack the weakness and just a bad piece
on c5 I mean it's not a no it's not a
bad piece but it it's the wrong position
for this piece and I don't have a move
here how do I ever get rid of the this
is just just a joke maybe I can do do
the
and intending bishop d aid
jump and white wins yeah 95 just just
not just stupid this is okay yeah well
he could have played as I mentioned just
group c 6 but this is check leading to
check excellent position simply with two
points maybe I can defend betters it's
okay and here hey I need to do something
better I don't know I don't know what
exactly but maybe I can somehow prevent
that he's got this dominant knight on d5
but I don't see it I really don't see it
the computer have it's it's quite funny
that the computer yeah this is okay this
is only stock fish for but it's not
terribly bad the same engine it it only
gives white 0.8 and I think why does
almost winning if I cannot generate
anything quickly white wins this is just
a steamroller in the center okay thanks
for watching